folie qui est avec nous au téléphone
liane foly pour bonsoir liane c'est fou
parce qu'en plus il nous est arrivé un
truc vous cette nuit parce que on est à
ses potes d'y aller moi et eux et on
discute et je vous jure à 4 heures du
matin par sms
il ya des mois et c'est moi qui a pris à
liane foly le décès de maurane en fait
yann oui je suis anéantie je n'en ai pas
pour moi c'était ma grand groupe g il ne
souhaitait pas sur dur et les méthodes
et on est sûr donner une histoire de
coeur on est sûr de son devoir de tout
on a partagé
quand je suis arrivé à paris c'est la
première que j'ai rencontrés avec jean
louis foulquier et on a traversé comme
ça 35 ans de notre vie ensemble c c'est
une perte immense parce que d'abord
c'était une femme merveilleuse comme tu
viens de dire cyril elle avait un humour
fou où elle était très long de villiers
c'est un accident qui venait d'arriver
en louisiane accroche donc voilà on lève
on l'aimera toujours sa voix est
inimitable irremplaçable et je voudrais
vraiment le dire il faut que les gens le
sachent les jeunes qui écoutent ses
doigts fabuleuse qui ne pourra jamais
c'est éternel ça et je voudrais vous
remercier les amis de ou d'être très
doux et un terrible nouvelle
c'est une terrible nouvelle yan yan je
voudrais te remercier d'avoir été avec
nous soit tu voulais nous dit anti
austérité très très très ému on pense
bien à ce que la famille de mourad on
pense à tous les belges aux siens qui
sont aujourd'hui dans la crise et puis
tout aujourd'hui c'est du tout les
techniciens des musiciens l'arrêt tous
ces gens qu'il aimait tant de la dorada
j'ai une femme merveilleuse
voilà je vous fais mieux tombera sur
l'effort merci diane lamarre est avec
nous